des câbles que l'on retire avant de
démanteler les pylônes un des nombreux
chantiers hérité de 99
car après la tempête le réseau
électrique est fortement endommagé
328 mille foyers sont privés
d'électricité le matin du 26 décembre
encore 120000 trois jours après et
quelques dizaines de milliers toujours
pas rétabli pour la saint sylvestre
l'ampleur des dégâts à un site erdf
devenu et médis à enfouir ces lignes en
vingt ans la proportion double ans entre
val de loire 43 % du réseau 20000 volts
passe désormais sous terre il est vrai
que depuis 99 nous à sensibilisons notre
réseau aérien sur toutes les parties
boisées les partis qui font l'objet des
incidents récurrents et des
organisations qui se met en place
à la suite de cette fameuse autant pas
99 entre autres la fir la force
d'intervention rapide électricité mais
également des investissements sur le
réseau pour le sécuriser pour
l'automatiser et pour rétablir
on veut dire la clientèle en énergie
électrique le plus rapidement possible
autre secteur conduit à modifier ses
méthodes de travail
la météorologie à l'époque météo france
communique surtout avec les autorités il
est décidé après la tempête de mieux
prévenir le grand public et d'affiner
les niveaux de risque les cartes de
vigilance sont mises en place
après analyse on a considéré qu'il
fallait faire un peu ce se caler sur ce
qui a été fait dans les territoires
d'outre-mer où il ya les alertes
cycloniques qui sont en place depuis
depuis longtemps donc avec un système de
code couleur en fonction de la sévérité
du risque attendus et les habitants de
de ces territoires sont habitués et
savent pas très bien quel comportement
adopter pour ce pour se protéger et à
miami du risque un peu partout météo
france se dote aussi de capteurs de
mesure du vent supplémentaires six sont
disposés en indre et loire contre un
seul auparavant
si l'ampleur de la tempête de 1999 reste
inégalé à l'avenir le réchauffement
climatique pourrait rendre plus
violentes les tempêtes hivernales